un homme a deux enfants l'un d'eux est
un garçon quelle est la probabilité que
l'autre soit un garçon aussi il ya
quelques mois je vous ai posé cette
énigme fantastique et je vous ai demandé
de la méditer en long en large et en
travers
et pour vous aider dans cette réflexion
je vous ai présenté deux solutions
contradictoire au problème la solution
'un répond un tiers et la solution de
répons 1/2
vous avez été nombreux à défendre l'une
ou l'autre des solutions ou à simplement
dire je ne sais pas ou encore à dire que
le problème est mal posé
et c'est fascinant je trouve que pour
une énigme aussi simple il y ait tant de
réponses aussi différentes ça suggère
que chacun d'entre nous adopte des
fondements différent pour ce qu'est un
raisonnement juste et valides
nous utilisons des manières différentes
de transformer de l'information aux
conclusions des méthodes distinctes de
transformer des données en croyances
nous nous reposons sur d épistémologie
différentes y compris quand on réfléchit
longuement aujourd'hui je vous propose
de découvrir la solution qui me semble
être la bonne
si on applique rigoureusement la
méthodologie bayésienne et je ne vais
pas prétendre que ma solution est la
bonne solution
je vais juste prétendre que c'est la
solution bayésienne à la question
autrement dit elle ne sera convaincante
que pour ceux parmi vous qui accepte
pleinement les prémices du paysagisme
pour les autres bas ne vous inquiète pas
j'aurai largement l'occasion plus tard
dans cette série de vous présenter
longuement beaucoup d'arguments en
faveur du bannissement
mais avant d'en arriver à la solution by
viennent arrêtons nous sur les deux
solutions proposées dans l'épisode 1 et
pour commencer on va voir pourquoi le
raisonnement utilisé pour en arriver à
la réponse un tiers est fallacieux
souvenez-vous dans la réponse
1 on commencer par identifier quatre
théorie est qu probable à savoir garçon
garçon garçon fille fille garçon et
fille et on avait dit que la donne et
qui dit qu'un des deux enfants est un
garçon disqualifié l'option khlifi il
restait alors trois possibilités dont
seulement une était compatible avec la
possibilité que l'autre soit un garçon
voyous et le sophisme le problème c'est
que ce qui importe pour mettre à jour
les crédences ce n'est pas la
compatibilité d'une théorie avec les
données observées ce qui importe
celle ci dans le cadre d'une théorie les
données observées sont prévisibles et à
quel point elles sont prévisibles
ce qui importe elle
invraisemblances des données sachant la
théorie pas la compatibilité des données
avec la théorie qu'insiste un peu plus
car cette distinction me semble
fondamental et car en pratique on se
pose si souvent la question de la
compatibilité des données plutôt que de
leur vraisemblance or chercher la
compatibilité c'est se donner du jeu
pour permettre le raisonnement motivés
et le biais de confirmation
en effet quand on veut croire une
théorie t on a tendance à chercher des
explications pour que des étranges
donner des demeure compatible avec thé
ou se demandent si sachant d on peut
néanmoins croire t voilà une mauvaise
question à se poser
en tout cas selon le bdia nisme il faut
en fait se demander si ça chantait les
données des sont prévisibles ou
surprenantes
il faut se demander à quel point tu es
prédit des sites et nécessitent des
hypothèses additionnel improbable pour
prédire des comme bio les lois de la
physique ou faire appel aux aliens c'est
que tu es seul ne prédit pas bien d il
est en fait la une tension entre le bas
et sionisme et de nombreuses versions de
la méthode scientifique qui s'appuie
notamment sur le rejet d'hypothèses
incompatible avec les données ou du
moins si une épistémologie repose
exclusivement sur la notion de
compatibilité
la fim différence du niveau de
prédictibilité des données par
différentes théories échappera à cette
épistémologie en tout cas telle est le
sophisme fallacieux de la réponse 1 ou
du moins il semble que le fait que la
probabilité des données sachant garçon
garçon
sachons garçon fille ou sachant
fille-garçon le fait que ces trois
probabilités sont les mêmes demandent
davantage de justification le
raisonnement de la réponse un pêche dans
le calcul des termes d'expérience de
penser
notez bien que je juge ici le
raisonnement de la réponse de pas la
réponse de elle-même c'est vraiment le
raisonnement qui m'importe ici et du
coup on peut se dire que la bonne
réponse est nécessairement la réponse de
sauf que non ou du moins le raisonnement
de la réponse de est également
fallacieux souvenez-vous le raisonnement
de la réponse d'eux consistait à classer
les enfants selon l'ordre dans lequel on
en apprend le sexe et on avait dit que
le premier enfant dont on découvre le
sexe a autant de chances d'être un
garçon et une fille et qu'il en était de
même du second enfant
indépendamment du sexe du premier enfant
autrement dit les quatre théorie garçon
garçon garçon fifi gars
et fifi semble a priori et qu probable
sauf que non cet a priori est en tout
cas potentiellement fallacieux pourquoi
eh bien à cause de l'homme n'est présent
biais de sélection
en effet imaginons que le parent doit
montrer qu'il a un garçon pour avoir un
certificat
j'ai un garçon alors l'enfant que le
parent va montrer ne sera pas une fille
dans ce scénario le premier enfant dont
on découvre le sexe a peu de chances
d'être une fille car le parent va
d'abord chercher à sélectionner un
garçon parmi ces enfants de la même
façon du coup ci se trouve que le sexe
du premier enfant dont on découvre le
sexe est plus probablement un garçon
alors il faut s'attendre à ce que
l'identité du second enfant dont on
découvre le sexe soit plus probablement
une fille
quoi qu'il en soit dans un cadre général
il est fallacieux de supposer que a
priori si on classe les enfants par
l'ordre dans lequel on en découvre
l'identité les quatre théorie garçon
garçon garçon fille fille garçon et
fille sont est plus probable le
raisonnement de la réponse de pêche dans
le calcul des préjugés on peut passer à
la solution by then à ce problème
si vous croyez vraiment balzani sme
cette solution devrait vous paraître
convaincante mais disclaimer alerts ci
vous n'êtes pas encore familier avec le
paysagisme je préfère vous prévenir
cette solution by then va probablement
vous paraître très étrange
donc je vous demande de d'abord cherché
à comprendre la logique parisienne
autrement dit pour aujourd'hui je vous
demande de faire l'expérience de pensée
selon laquelle le boys and his mme et la
bonne épistémologie car ne l'oubliez pas
sans expérience de pensée les
alternatives sont inévitablement négligé
pour appliquer le bail à nice mme il
nous faut commencer par établir un
préjugé comme on l'a vu le préjugé de la
réponse 2 est problématique mais celui
de la réponse 1 semble parfaitement
adéquat on va donc considérer le préjugé
suivant a priori lorsqu'ils sont classés
par âge on a probabilité de garçon
garçon est égale à la probabilité de
garçons filles qui est égal à
probabilité de file garçon qui était
égal à la probabilité de fifi qui est
égal à 1 car si vous voulez une
explication plus intuitif de ce préjugé
je vous renvoie vers cette excellente
vidéo de monsieur fille qui illustre
tout ça avec des cartes à jouer pour
déterminer nos crédence a posteriori il
va maintenant nous falloir calculer les
termes d'expérience de penser c'est à
dire la probabilité des données des
sachants
vers théorie t mais quel est cet automne
était bien il semble que le sophisme de
toutes les approches que j'ai lu de
cette énigme des deux enfants vient
d'une mauvaise identification de cette
donnée d oui parce que bien souvent on a
tendance à remplacer la donne est
vraiment observer des par une
interprétation des chapeaux que l'on a
de cette donnée par exemple dans le cas
de la réponse 1
beaucoup de commentaires ainsi que la
page wikipedia affirme que d un chapeau
est égal à au moins un garçon est du
coup en effet les termes d'expérience de
penser probabilité de d un chapeau ça
chantait associés aux théories garçon
garçon garçons filles et six garçons
sont toutes égales à 1 après application
de la formule de bise on obtient alors
bel et bien probabilité de garçon garçon
sachant d un chapeau est égale à un
tiers
al'inverse dans le cas de la réponse de
beaucoup de commentaires et certaines
sections de wikipédia utilise en fait
des deux chapeaux qui est égal à x était
un garçon ou x est tiré au hasard parmi
les enfants
cette fois on a alors probabilité de d2
chapeau sachant le garçon garçon est
égal à 1 mais probabilité de d2 chapeau
sachant qu'ils garçon est égal à
probabilité de d2 chapeau sachant
garçons filles est égal à 1,2 me en
effet dont le premier cas si on suppose
la théorie garçons deux garçons vrai
alors qu on est sûr que x est un garçon
mais dans les deux autres cas on est à
moitié surpris de tomber sur un garçon
on aurait tout aussi bien pu tomber sur
une fille et après application de la
formule de bise on obtient un bel et
bien probabilité de garçon garçon
sachant des deux chapeaux est égal à un
demi là encore tout est encore mieux
expliquées par me sophie dans cette
vidéo vraiment aller la voir aller
vraiment super chouette mais là données
que je vous ai fourni est en fait une
idée un chapeau ni des deux chapeaux ce
que je vous ai dit cd est égal à l'un
d'eux est un garçon en parlant des deux
enfants et ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai mis du temps à comprendre et à
accepter dont la formule de bize les
données observées ce ne sont pas des
interprétations des données
ça ne doit pas être des interprétations
des données oui car ses interprétations
des données serait alors à effectuer par
des humains probablement non bayésiens
et potentiellement sujet à toutes sortes
de biens cognitif à commencer par le
raisonnement motivé
justement le baiser nisme prétend être
une philosophie universel du savoir
supérieur à toute alternative y compris
le raisonnement intuitif des humains
pour être purement bayésiens il nous
faut alors interdire toute intervention
de l'intuition humaine et ça commence
par appliquer la formule de base à des
données brutes pas à des données que
notre intuition a reformulé du coup pour
appliquer la formule de bise
il nous faut calculer les termes
d'expérience de penser probabilité de
death à chanter ou des et la phrase l'un
d'eux est un garçon autrement dit pour
tes est égale un garçon garçon
quelle est la probabilité que l'on nous
dise l'un d'eux est un garçon et ça
c'est une question difficile mais si on
peut faire plusieurs remarques la
probabilité de cette donnée est
probablement faible quand vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui a deux enfants
quelle est la probabilité qu'ils se
mettent à dire l'un d'eux est un garçon
probablement pas égal à un autre
remarque étrange la réponse à cette
question semble nécessairement
contextuel il y à des contextes où
sachant garçon garçon il est plus
probable qu'on nous dise
l'un d'eux est un garçon typiquement si
la discussion préalable concernés et
clubs de football pour garçons en fait
la réponse à l'énigme des deux enfants
semblent dépendre du contexte dans
lequel elle est posée pire elle dépend
même probablement de la personne qui
pose cette question car différentes
personnes s'intéressent plus ou moins
sexe des enfants des autres et ont donc
des probabilités différentes d'affirmer
l'un d'eux avec un garçon d'ailleurs il
est même probable qu'il soit plus
probable d'affirmer l'un d'eux est un
garçon lorsque seulement 1 des enfants
est un garçon autrement dit au moins
dans certains contextes il ne semble pas
déraisonnable d'avoir probabilité de des
sachants garçon garçon inférieure à la
probabilité de des sachants fille garçon
et probabilité de garçon garçon
inférieur à probabilité de des sachants
garçons filles
dès lors on aurait probabilité de garçon
garçon inférieure à un tiers et oui au
final sachant qu'on me dit l'un d'eux
est un garçon il me semble en fait plus
probable que l'autre enfant a en fait
bien peu de chances d'être un garçon
enfin la dernière remarque que je vais
faire au sujet de cette énigme est la
plus étrange
selon le pur baïse à nice mme la réponse
à l'énigme est en fait fondamentalement
subjective car elle dépend en fait
fortement des connaissances de base
autre que d autrement dit il faut
s'attendre à ce que différents
observateurs avec 10
ambac guen knowledge parts d'à priori
différents et aboutissent du cou à des
crédences a posteriori différentes
on reviendra plus longuement sur cette
notion quand on parlerait de l'inférence
bazine cumulés mais je peux d'ores et
déjà vous renvoyer vers cette superbe
vidéo d'hygiène mentale à ce sujet
typiquement si vous connaissez les
enfants de cet homme et sa vie avant
d'apprendre dès qu'il s'agissait de deux
garçons alors votre préjugés sur leur
sexe c'est à dire vos crédits ans avant
d'apprendre des serait en fait très
différentes et vous seriez sûr que
l'autre est un garçon aussi du coup vous
conclut riez probabilité de garçon
garçon sachant d est égal à 1 a
posteriori aussi de manière moins
extrêmes si vous saviez a priori que
votre interlocuteur ne dit jamais la
phrase
l'un d'eux est un garçon lorsque les
deux enfants sont des garçons alors vous
conclut riez probabilité de garçon
garçon sachant d est égal à zéro et
enfin si vous saviez que votre
interlocuteur se trompe souvent vous
pourriez même conclure qu il demeure
possible que l'enfant est en fait deux
filles
autrement dit vous conclut riez
probabilité de fifi sachant d est
strictement positive
alors oui je sais ça peut paraître très
insatisfaisant tout ça en attendant
surtout en maths à vouloir avoir une
réponse unique à laquelle toute personne
intelligente parviendrait et là la
réponse à l'énigme semble
malheureusement subjective et nonu yves
roques cependant j'insiste dessus la
réponse parisienne a beau être
subjective et n'a rien d'arbitraire
elle est le résultat d'un calcul
bayésiens très rigoureux et si on le
fait bien
si on est bien conscient des données à
considérer et des préjugés à avoir alors
le raisonnement bayésiens ne nous laisse
pas le choix
le va-et-vient doit croire le résultat
de son calcul mais pour finir cet
épisode j'aimerais insister sur un point
que nous apprend le baiser nisme s'il ya
un désaccord entre deux individus
honnête et intelligent sur une
prédiction malgré des données observées
commune c'est sans doute parce que ces
individus avaient des préjugés
différents et la cause de la divergence
des préjugés réside probablement dans
l'observation de données antérieures
différentes
comme chaque individu n'a pas observé
les données antérieures de l'autre il
gagnera à s'informer à leur sujet pour
affiner ses prédictions baïse yens voilà
une raison de plus de débattre à
condition bien sûr de bien débattre une
petite annonce jeu
auray alliance en ce week-end du 13 14
avril en particulier dimanche je
donnerai une conférence sur le thème
l'infini mythe ou réalité est par
ailleurs achevée vous donner les énigmes
dont on parlera la semaine prochaine
puisque on reviendra sur des variantes
que cette énigme et et deux enfants
la première énigme est la suivante un
homme a deux enfants et vous rencontrer
l'un de ses enfants dans les toilettes
des garçons et du coup c'est un garçon
quelle est la probabilité que l'autre
soit un garçon aussi à 2m enigmo dit
qu'un homme a deux enfants et vous lui
demandez avez vous au moins un enfant né
un mardi daigo répond oui la question
ensuite c'est quelle est la probabilité
que l'autre enfant soit un garçon aussi
enfin la troisième énigme et on parlera
c'est du sondage de michael au néon
mentionnera également les variantes hoc
dont pas parler monsieur filles dans
cette superbe vidéo que je recommande
vivement la nappe en a parlé de
problèmes de monty rôle on a vu qu'il a
dérouté énormément de gens y compris des
mathématiciens et franck demande si ces
mathématiciens il n'aurait pas pu faire
même des simulations certains n'avaient
pas d'ordinateur à cette époque mais il
aurait très bien pu faire ça sur papier
et la réponse est non ils n'ont pas fait
de simulation tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'on est convaincu la raison bah
pourquoi faire des simulations et je
rajouterais même que j'aurais tendance à
faire beaucoup plus confiance au final à
la formule de base qui a des simulations
parce qu'il ya pas mal de choses qui
peuvent mal se passer dans une
simulation simplement ça peut être mal
codé
c'est souvent l'hypothèse la plus
probable mais également il peut avoir
juste des déviations publiquement dans
une émission de la bbc
marcus dusautois et allan davis ont fait
des simulations du poème de monty roth
ils ont observé 30 qu'a dit ouah en
changeant de rideau et seulement 6
victoires en ne changeant pas de rideau
ce qui semble infirmer le résultat
théorique 2/3 1/3 les simulations pose
également leurs problèmes et
techniquement avec des simulations on
pourra jamais être sûr à 100% que les
bonnes réponses on exactement aux 2/3 et
1/3
bref les simulations ne permettent pas
de résultat mathématique solide ne
permettent pas de prouver en particulier
des progrès mais ils peuvent aider à
aiguilles et l'intuition vers les bonnes
réponses
et d'ailleurs comme marie n'gbo savante
a reçu sa shipstern elle répondait
justement aux jambes a fait les
simulations chez vous et lui a tout un
mouvement aux etats-unis ou dans
beaucoup de
face à l'école les enfants faisait des
simulations dumontier rôle pour se
rendre compte à quel point ce problème
était contre intuitif ce qu'il est
d'ailleurs boussuge aide de problème a
posé également à l'école
j'imagine je passais une bille de sens
de l'attaqué ça en riant 32-27 fait la
remarque que marié une fosse à 29 avait
pas de diplôme en mathématiques et ça a
sans doute contribué au à la
condescendance de pas mal de gens
notamment ceux qui avaient une thèse qui
se disait brel sait pas de quoi elle
parlait du coup ils se sont permis de
critiquer sa démonstration sans y voir
beaucoup réfléchi et en effet je pense
que c'est un gros problème cette idée
que il faut avoir des diplômes pour
faire des mathématiques de façon
générale ont bien sûr on peut avoir une
méfiance tout à fait légitime envers les
personnes qui n'ont pas de diplôme en
mathématiques mais s'il démontre une
certaine aisance avec les mathématiques
il n'y a pas de raison de penser qu'ils
seraient moins bons y compris que des
mathématiciens et ça ça me permet de
parler de quelqu'un d'autre qui n'a pas
de diplôme de mathématiques et je trouve
absolument ahurissant qui est vie sauce
d'achêne vis hausse s'il me trompe pas
le plus grand youtuber éducatif au monde
viçosa priori n'a pas de diplôme du tout
en mathématiques et pourtant je pense
que sa vidéo sur le paradoxe de bonnes à
retard ce qui montre bien qui comprend
mieux ce problème que beaucoup de gens
qui auront une thèse en mathématiques
en tout cas moi quand j'avais mon
doctorat en mathématiques je n'avais
absolument pas le niveau de
compréhension du paradoxe de banhars
tarski que vie sos et plus généralement
je trouve ça assez dommage que on a
tendance à supposer qu'il y a les
mathématiciens d'un côté et les noms
mathématiciens de l'autre qui est un
réflexe mais heureusement que je trouve
assez récurrent et du coup j'aimerais
vous parler d'eux au moins deux autres
personnes qui ont longtemps été
catalogué comme mauvais en maths et qui
sont devenus des gens absolument
brillant en maths
à commencer par looking glass universe
qui tient à mon sens la meilleure
chienne de youtube sur la mécanique
quantique et qui parle de beaucoup
d'aspect assez important des
mathématiques pour la mécanique
quantique en particulier le l'ag moins
linéaire or comme l explique très bien
dans cette vidéo pendant longtemps été
catalogué comme mauvaise en
mathématiques et
ces enseignants parce qu'elle n'aurait
aucune chance de développer une carrière
qui nécessitent des mathématiques en
tout cas clairement pas l'algorithmique
quantique et l'autre exemple encore plus
époustouflant de tout ça c'est un mec
qui s'appelle john pew il ya un article
sur lui qui est absolument fantastique
qui explique que lui aussi en en
longtemps ces enseignants disait de lui
qu'il n'avait aucune faculté
mathématiques et qui était même mauvais
en mathématiques et la juste abandonné
les mathématiques
et puis des années plus tard par
accident et s'est mis à s'intéresser aux
mathématiques a rencontré des gens qui
ont motivé à faire des mathématiques et
aujourd'hui il est l'un des plus grands
mathématiciens au monde qui travaille
notamment à une institution dyson se
disent à consonance qu'il travaillait à
l'époque où cet article est sorti et est
même pressenti pour la médaille fields
il n'a pas reçu la meute et qu'il
recevra la prochaine fois ce mec
aujourd'hui est juste un monstre eu
pendant longtemps il avait été catalogué
comme mauvais en mathématiques et il se
pensait lui-même mauvais qu'en
mathématiques
je suis pas en train de dire que
n'importe lequel d'entre nous peut
devenir john key mais clairement si vous
vous pensez mauvais en mathématiques
j'ai envie de dire que quasiment par
nécessité ou n'exploiter absolument pas
tout le potentiel de compréhension des
mathématiques que vous avez et si vous
voulez devenir bon en mathématiques bas
la première étape qui nous semble c'est
juste de se permettre de parler un peu
plus de mathématiques et d'apprécier de
faire des mathématiques d'explorer le
monde mathématiques de faire d erreur
mathématique et j'espère que mes vidéos
contribuent à nourrir une certaine
passion des mathématiques
chez vous et j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo la pression on parlera donc
de trois variantes assez mind phoques de
ce problème des trois enfants
si vous avez vu cette vidéo à penser à
la ligue et à la commenter et à partager
pensez à vous abonner pour les futurs
épisodes versé au type erp lordon et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois ce serait un peu comme le problème
du monde qui volent pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est à dire un cas où il y
à bien une bonne réponse une réponse
correcte et c'est juste notre intuition
qui nous piège et j'étais assez surpris
donc d'entendre les dans cette première
vidéo parler du problème des enfants
comme d'un problème plus riche et plus
mystérieux que ça et sur lequel sa
position aurait en fait changé par
rapport à ce qu'il en dit dans son antre
et du coup j'y ai réfléchi aussi et avec
sa permission jeu
les faire une petite vidéo pour discuter
de ce problème qui effectivement est
bien plus intéressant que je ne l'avais
pensé au départ on peut en tirer vous
allez voir des leçons assez surprenante
bon alors voilà en fait ici la question
n'était pas vraiment bien posée et selon
la façon dont on la complète ou
l'interprète la bonne réponse et un demi
ou deux tiers mais notez que y'a rien de
quantic ou magique ici la bonne réponse
dépend seulement de la façon dont on
complète la question pour avoir un
problème bien posée et du coup bien
faute de mieux la meilleure réponse ici
était sans doute la réponse d